caramelized figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful Rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in rows take
some Rosemary and just peel that down
get that really nice fragrant stem get
your scissors trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp Point bring your three figs
together
and just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently Rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stock will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
the figs with icing sugar then coat them
with a generous splash of balsamic
vinegar leave them to sit there for five
minutes they sort of marinade I know it
sounds odd to use vinegar in your
dessert but trust me it gives the dish a
fantastic sweet and sour taste I'm gonna
make a really nice caramel four or five
tablespoons of sugar now flatten that
out and get it nice and even when the
sugar is even caramel Cooks evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in the one thing you
don't do is shake the pan rapidly
and sit almost like sort of a lake
defrosting and it's hitting to the
center it's bubbling it's still not dark
enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas another butter in
there
gently whisking
the butter is cooling the camel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe Olay
next add a dug of the balsamic vinegar
beautiful
for that nice dark richness
of a camel a little touch of water in
there
that way the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the caramel back on the heat
take a fix and sort of place them in
gently
lovely
and then just added all that lovely
little marinade
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar and Balsam and vinegar
so tasty
based those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside and the
Fig sort of just absorbs the caramel
delicious so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
they smell
is incredible
onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that camera
now douse the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese the
freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
I'm gonna finish that now
zest
and then some little nibbed almonds
and the rich creamy Jam texture of the
Fig
with a ricotta
brilliant that is an amazing way of slow
roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
spicy chutney
with Chutney standing by in the fridge
you can always add that special little
touch to a simple supper prove that
thinking ahead always pays off
pan on to start toasting those spices
keep the pan nice and low cumin very
aromatic very fragrant and it's almost
like a light spice next nice little
coriander seeds coriandering now you're
going to get a bit of heat in the
Chutney mustard seeds well smaller than
coriander seeds but so much more
powerful mustard seeds in
now Curry leaves they don't actually
smell much dry but the flavor they give
off is extraordinary Curly's in
really important not to burn them
otherwise you'll
have that bitter taste across the
Chutney keep the gas nice and low the
secret is sort of toastable so it
releases that oil and tensifies the
spice a touch of salt
and then a couple of small powerful
chilies keep them whole no one's going
to eat them but it gives that real nice
burst of heat
now let them toast gently there we're
not going to chop the onion we're going
to grate it
why
because it sort of breaks down to a
really nice puree in the Chutney when
you grate it hold the root in the palm
of your hand and just push
nice long straight
I want those nice long shards
look I've almost got a nice sort of
onion puree but it's nice and clear
touch a volleyball
spices nicely toasted onions in
[Music]
three nice cloves of garlic
crush them
[Music]
lay it nice and flat and just slice the
garlic
nice thin slices
garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelized beautifully will really reap
rewards in the long run
Tamarind paste and sugar in with the
sugar first three nice tablespoons of
sugar
that will give a really nice syrup
effect a sort of nice rich syrupy
texture to Chutney Tamarind paste
you can get Tamarind paste in most delis
and the big supermarkets
it's really nice thickening Asian but it
gives that tartness the Chutney and it's
sort of bridge sugary spicy
next in with my coconut add four nice
tablespoons that will give a nice body a
really nice texture to the Chutney cut
that coconut out and now add the carrot
greater
the carrot just gives the Chutney a
really nice sort of punch
but also helps to sort of cool down the
spice
carrots in
the water comes out of the carrot
flavors the Chutney beautifully but
gives that nice sort of vibrant bright
color to it as well
and grating it almost sort of it Cooks
instantly but I want a bit of texture
through here turn down the gas and just
let that simmer for five minutes
if the cars are that moist and juicy
then put a couple of tablespoons of
water in there to help it along
now
five minutes
just so those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly
spicy slightly sweet gas off
keep those chilies in there for that
it's beautiful nice and gooey delicious
and
ready to go in his jar AS that sits in
the fridge
just gets better and better and better
I love to eat this chutney with cold
meats or even cold fish but with ham
it's amazing
it's a really nice way of livening up
the ham
just sort of roll it up
get a nice spoon of Chutney I mean it
looks fantastic Chuck me onto the plate
serve and that is a nice little
gem in the fridge that is worth prepping
in advance for